three out of four Indian women are
unemployed that's more than Saudi Arabia
a country where women have only been
allowed to drive since
2018 this is no statistical slight of
hand in fact 3 out of four is wildly
conservative this number called the
labor force participation rate includes
both anyone with or without a job as
long as they're looking however
passively
of those 24% of women technically in the
labor force many don't actually
work then there's the question of what
counts as
employment in this case the answer is as
little as 1 hour each week of paid labor
put differently of India's 1.4 billion
people 681 million are women 9 million
of those are at least 15 years old 120
22 million officially in the labor force
and a tiny 38 million
88.8% according to one Indian Think Tank
meaningfully
employed in a country of 1.4 billion in
other words just 38 million women have
jobs the United States by contrast has
twice as many women employed in absolute
terms with only 1/4 the
population how can that possibly be true
could it be that Indian households are
now Rich enough to comfortably subsist
on one
income no far from it the country's per
capita GDP is less than
$2,400 just 1/5 the world average and
where China was about 20 years ago is it
because women lack access to education
according to the World Bank better
educated women are more likely to
participate in the formal labor market
again no strangely in India educated
women are less likely to find employment
college enrollment has soared since the
turn of the century yet women's
participation in the labor force has
actually been on a steady decline until
very
recently perhaps it's precisely because
women are in school studying rather than
working nope it's not that either since
older women are also missing from the
labor force
finally could it be an issue of personal
safety or cultural
expectations certainly this is a major
piece of the puzzle India is one of the
world's most dangerous countries for
women just getting two and from work
safely presents a not insignificant
challenge meanwhile 99% of Indian women
eventually get married 90% of those
marriages are arranged and women are
expected to do nearly all of the
housework an extraordinary 6% of men
report doing any cooking whatsoever and
only 8% do at least some
cleaning more of women's time spent
cooking and cleaning is less time for
paid labor Case
Closed except hang on take a look at
India's neighbor on three sides
Bangladesh the two countries rank nearly
identically on the women's peace
security index that is very poorly they
share many of the same cultural norms
practices and
beliefs and yet women in Bangladesh work
at a much higher rate clearly there's
much more to the story what's really
going
on the answer lies in this graph but
first a brief
aside in India like many countries a
family's honor depends on on the purity
of its daughters any time spent outside
the home for example at work exposes
women to accusations of promiscuity
tarnishing her family's honor parents
therefore strongly pressure their
daughters to stay home of course working
also has its benefits children are
expected to contribute
financially this presents a tradeoff
between income and honor and since honor
is more or less a constant the important
variable here are
wages for any given family is the extra
money generated by allowing your
daughter to work worth the damage to
your reputation and by extension her
marriage
prospects when families are poor this
loss of honor is strongly preferable to
the alternative starvation women have no
choice they have to work conversely when
wages are high they offset this honor
penalty causing women to rejoin the
workforce India as a country is stuck at
the bottom of this U curve what Dr Alice
Evans of King's College London calls the
patrilineal Trap wages are just barely
high enough that families can scrape by
on one income but not high enough to
draw women back to the
workplace women are trapped between low
wages and suffocating social
norms they do go to college though
mainly to find a husband and they do
want to work in a recent survey 75% of
teenage girls said they hope to find a
job after graduating the problem is that
wages aren't high enough to convince
their
families the real mystery then is why
Indian wages are still so incredibly
low since 1990 its economy has grown at
an impressive average rate of 6% a year
not so far behind China's miraculous
88.8% back then India was only the
world's 12th largest economy today it's
the fifth yet somehow this spectacular
growth failed to create any jobs now
economists call the number of new jobs
produced for every 1% change in GDP the
elasticity of Labor well between 2011
and 19 the Indian labor force grew by
0.26% imputing an elasticity of 0
.04 which is a polite way of saying
virtually zero jobs were created over 10
years this implies that if its economy
were to double overnight employment
would only increase by
4% between 1999 and 2005 60 million new
jobs appeared between 2004 and 10 just
three the result is fierce competition
for every last scrap of paid work in
2019 12 million people applied for
35,000 railroad jobs and 1.7 million
for500 jobs at a state-owned bank most
of these applicants Are Young and the
vast majority college educated those who
are both young and college educated
don't stand a chance today 42% of
Indians under 25 with graduate degrees
can't find
work so what do all these young scholars
do they go back to school of course
fueling a race to acquire an increasing
number of unnecessary credentials or
else fall
behind others simply lose hope and spend
their days doing what Indians call time
pass aimless
Leisure now one clue to the whereabouts
of these missing jobs is the country's
most common occupation not salesperson
waiter or janitor but CEO truly you see
contrary to the image of sweat shops
many Around the World Imagine Indian
employers are actually quite tightly
regulated legally they must provide
workers with paid leave pensions and
health insurance they even need
permission from the government to fire
or lay them off at least in
principle in practice most of these laws
only apply to businesses with 10 or more
employees and unrelatedly for some odd
reason Indian companies seem to have
decided nine is the optimal number of
workers so what do you know the vast
majority of businesses are exempt from
these
regulations another reason they stay
small is to evade corruption companies
with 10 or more workers are visited by
labor inspectors many of which enforce
Arcane rules to extract
bribes thus whereas China has a healthy
balance of midsize companies many of
which have between 51 and 200 workers
over 80% of Indian apparel firms for
instance have less than eight with so
many small businesses it's no wonder
India has perhaps the world's highest
density of
CEOs as companies grow rather than hire
more workers they simply Outsource this
additional labor to other small
companies but this loophole clever as it
is has a cost smaller companies are less
productive on average those with 50 to
199 workers are about 60% less
productive than those with over 200 and
those with 5 to 49 workers about 90%
less
productive lower productivity means
lower wages lower wages means less
consumer demand and less demand means
fewer jobs not just fewer but also lower
quality only 21% % of Indian workers
earn regular
wages of them 46% don't receive any paid
leave 53% don't receive Social Security
and nearly 60% have no written contract
at all this flexibility as employers
call it is stressful and unpredictable
during the best of times when things are
anything less than peachy these informal
jobs become downright
catastrophic like say during a global
pandemic in 2020 the Prime Minister
declared what began as a 3-we national
lockdown which immediately put 100
million Indians out of work who fled in
Mass to the countryside the only place
they could go by December of that year
75 million people had been plunged below
the poverty line of $2 a day according
to Pew
research but there's another bigger
structural reason why India has so few
jobs
of the countries that successfully
escaped poverty in the last 100 years
almost all have pursued the same tried
and true development recipe a rapid
progression from agriculture to
manufacturing to services in that order
it worked for Taiwan Hong Kong Singapore
South Korea and now
China India on the other hand seems to
have somehow missed this memo by the
time its economy liberalized and the
early 1990s China was already 10 years
into this journey and having started so
late Indian factories couldn't compete
with their Chinese competitors so they
largely gave up instead India skipped
straight from agriculture to Services
leaving out that very critical middle
step in the recipe
manufacturing today Vietnam with a
population of less than 100 million
exports more clothing than India with a
population of 1.4
billion now there's nothing wrong with
Services nearly all rich countries are
service economies from the US to Japan
and
Switzerland so you might think India
found a shortcut the country has an
impressive depth of Finance Insurance
real estate and Technology
expertise deoy Goldman and Tata pay
their Indian consultants and bankers top
dollar much more of of course than most
Factory
workers the problem is that there just
aren't that many of these jobs as Indian
Farmers have grown more productive as
they have across the globe agriculture
has been on a steady decline no surprise
there usually however all these Farmers
would become Factory workers one labor
intensive industry replaced with another
but as you can see manufacturing hasn't
absorbed these displaced farmers
sure these new service jobs have helped
just not nearly enough so in order to
make up the difference Indians have
flocked to
construction these jobs are often
temporary low paid and physically
dangerous but this trend is particularly
bad for women in East Asia where
manufacturing replaced agriculture women
became Factory workers which slowly
influenced social expectations and
afforded them new found freedom in India
women were pushed out of farming but
discouraged from taking on construction
a few lucky women secured lucrative
service jobs but the vast majority
simply left the labor market
altogether they had nowhere to
go this is why India's economy continued
to grow those new service jobs are very
very productive while the number of jobs
did not they're few and far between
it's why women in Bangladesh work at
much higher rates its manyu factories
provide them with a socially acceptable
place to do so whereas India has no such
scale what India does have that most of
Asia does not is
time China's population peaked last year
and its labor force is expected to
decrease by about 1% each year starting
in
2030 India meanwhile is still very much
young and growing 40% of its population
is under the age of 25 and 53% under 30
its median age is a youthful 28 compared
to China's 38 or Japan's
48 with any luck India has about two
decades remaining in its demographic
window a critical transition period
during which a country has a large
number of working age people compared to
children and
retirees if the country can harness
nness this labor it could still
experience a taste of the demographic
dividend that propelled China from a
poor to a middle inome country by merely
employing women at the same rate as men
according to Bloomberg India's economy
could grow by nearly a third by
2050 but if it waste this opportunity
these excess young people could become a
demographic burden in that case it would
be stuck with millions of angry aimless
and unemployed 20 30 and 40y
olds simply put India has no time to
waste which means it may need some help
from David Allen in his book getting
things done on today's sponsor imprint
in it for example I learned the five
stages of being productive and when to
put something on my to-do list versus
calendar these days no one can keep up
with the endless stream of new books
movies and knowledge never mind catch up
on all of history but imprint condenses
these lessons into bite-sized Visual and
interactive lessons not unlike these
videos making you more widely read and
culturally aware in less time instead of
scrolling mindlessly through Instagram
wouldn't you rather check out those
classic Works you've always heard about
but never had time to sit down and read
like Guns Germs and Steel or Malcolm
gladwell's
outliers in addition to book summaries
imprint also has lessons on current
events
like Russia's war in Ukraine and
interactive explanations for example of
History's great philosophical thinkers
to start learning today click the link
on screen or in the description for a
free 7-Day trial the first 200 to click
that link will also get 20% off an
annual premium
subscription